[Music]
hello you're playing the waiting game
the show that recommends five things for
you to check out before the latest
gaming hits land it's kind of like the
family fortunes of games you can't fire
yet except we don't have any dismembered
bouncing testicles in our intro you know
what game has loads of dismembered non
testicle body parts the evil within it's
a gruesome survival horror title from
mr. Shinji Mikami due to land in late
August 2014 on ps3 ps4 360 Xbox one and
PC within the game the evil is a
mysterious force that overpowers
detectives Sebastian Castellanos and his
partners at the scene of a murder
cracking name by the way from there he
must travel through a world of death and
madness facing his own fears in order to
understand what is going on and
presumably not die horribly again with
the dismemberment
[Music]
now first up if you haven't done so
already you have to play Silent Hill
this 1999 playstation title is a classic
piece of psychological horror that was
so good it resulted in eight more games
in the series an HD re-release of the
first three and a full feature film our
hero Harry Mason is no hero
he's an every man's man who happens to
have lost his daughter in a foggy town
full of horrible monsters you're every
man's health means that only a few hits
will bring you down and with no heads-up
display it's something you have to
actively check investigating the
mysterious powers that ensnare the town
and battling it's creepy occupants will
lead you to one of five grim endings
there's also a spoof ending as well with
some little alien dudes possibly some
probing but you don't want to hear about
that it's available on PSN so you won't
even need to dust off your old ps1
either check out the lousy film too if
you like if only for the scene where
Pyramid Head throw some one's flesh
against a church door like a moist
towelette sure let the evil within also
has this rather large ugly fella
maniacally running around messing up
corpses hanging from meat hooks
[Music]
exactly and once you're done with that
you should watch the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre originally released in 1974
this story focuses on a group of friends
who run foul of a cannibal family with a
pawn shop or chainsaws the film's main
antagonist Leatherface arguably set the
bar for hulking masked killers along
with introducing power tools as a funny
way of dispatching pretty all-american
beauties into more manageable digestible
chunks what happened was true don't
believe for a second that the film is a
true story because it's not but it's
scary as all hell and well worth your
time if you have a taste for horror if
all out fear is your bag then look no
further than siren blood curse this 2008
ps3 title was directed by CAI Ichiro
Toyama the same guy to direct option
number one Silent Hill
siren blood curse adds a new level of
fear to the game by allowing you to see
through the eyes of your hunter as you
peek through the gaps of your hiding
place at times you can even see your own
eyes looking back at you hiding from
Rocky with a chainsaw is something
you'll be doing a lot of in the evil
within hi GameSpot's Jess MacDonald
describes it as [ __ ] siren blood curse
that's the scariest [ __ ] game I've
ever played that's about a shining a
recommendation as you can get one thing
that evil within doesn't want for is
buckets of blood and gore out of which
sprouts something that has altogether
too many limbs and a face like a bag of
smashed crabs you're on a roof [ __ ]
kidding so when an alien life-form takes
over the bodies of a crew working in an
Arctic station in the thing it's all
limbs and weird faces are plenty they'll
have to figure out who is still human
and who has a chest cavity made of teeth
for example
this film doesn't hold back on the gore
one bit and being an older film it's all
done with prosthetics rather than silly
CGI so it looks just that extra bit
horrendous a long time ago before Shinji
Mikami started working on evil within he
was working on a little-known horror
series by the name of Resident Evil and
it was excellent ups of Resident Evil 4
I mean then he did other things and
after that resi just went all action Ian
wrong originally released back in 96
Chris Redfield and Jill Valentine
investigates a series of mysterious
murders on the outskirts of Raccoon City
but it's not long until they're trapped
in a puzzle trap and zombie ridden
mansion the umbrella corporation has
been conducting illegal experiments with
something known as the t-virus and the
side effects can be less than savory
Resident Evil is known for its fixed
camera angles and attacking mechanic
making it really hard to see what's at
the end of a corridor and harder still
to aim your very limited ammunition at
whatever is trying to kill you
much like Silent Hill your actions in
game will also lead to a multitude of
different endings
once again this series made its way to
Hollywood in the form of two CGI and no
less than five live-action movies with a
sixth in the works right now trashy
action with Mila Djokovic it's a guilty
pleasure
another week another five suggestions no
books this time so do leave your own
recommendations in the comments below or
tweet them to me at Ready Steady Go
using the hashtag GS waiting game a bit
like how I didn't include Doctor Who
last week so I'm sorry about that I'll
see you next week
[Music]